so my talk is biz buzzkill and we'll
talk about that in a second but this is
related to the concept of questions you
might get in an interview I am Russell
Anderson I am a husband and a father I
live here in Nashville in Englewood I'm
a Christian I'm also a terrible golfer
though it's probably my favorite hobby
it keeps me humble very humble and I'm
real real Russ on Twitter I work for a
company called simply agree it's a
start-up here in town and we are
workflow software for attorneys
specifically transactional attorneys at
this point I am a front-end developer
and I think that you can all glean from
this weekend that that that is a like
multitude of tasks and tools I've been
doing it full-time about five years and
I have no sort of outside computer not
computer science schooling or anything
I'm completely self-taught but really
I'm mostly colleague taught I've kind of
leaned on a lot of really nice really
good people at the jobs that I've been
fortunate to have to kind of teach me
what I know and I've mostly worked like
in everywhere that I've worked I've I've
used JavaScript but it's always been in
the context of a framework or library
back in the day that was jQuery and
backbone it's been angular it's been
react but it's always been in this
context the irony of the picture that I
chose here is that if if the apocalypse
were to happen I would be not be able to
use any of these actual tools I would
want to build software and be completely
useless but the inspiration for this
talk is there's a designer that I
followed named Brad Frost and he wrote a
post last year actually called why I'm
not a JavaScript developer and he
basically took a list of front-end
interview questions specific to drop in
JavaScript
that is on the html5 boilerplate github
and he sort of took every question and
wrote kind of a smartass remark to it so
for instance he said why is it called a
ternary expression what does the word
ternary indicate ternary means it
involves three things and strings them
all two on one line so it's harder to
read and then he said create a loop so
this is the the fizzbuzz question create
a loop that iterates up to 100 while
outputting fizz and multiples of three
buzz at multiples of five and fizzbuzz
at multiples of three and five so this
is a actual kind of standard coding
question and his response was that
sounds hard and for some strange reason
I am suddenly jonesing for dr. pepper
and so it was funny I read it and I was
like oh yeah that's that's funny but it
was like he was funny but then I thought
I I don't know that I could answer those
questions like I use JavaScript every
day and I build software with it but I
these seem kind of basic and I don't
know the answer to them so and I figured
that I'm probably not alone in that like
you can actually build a lot of awesome
stuff with the tools that you use and
not completely understand the tools
themselves so I took thought a good talk
idea was to take some of these questions
and just try and answer them and answer
them like succinctly as if I would have
to be in an interview and maybe give
some real-world application to them but
before I jump into the questions
themselves they kind of want to address
the point of like our interview
questions are they a are they a good
idea I I think that this is definitely
something and if you're a junior
developer and you're gonna be you're
going to be going to a lot of interviews
and you're gonna probably doing a lot of
code tests and things like that or if
you're a hiring manager looking at it
from the other way you should know that
a lot of times putting people on the
spot with things like this is
essentially creating a adversarial
relationship with the person that you're
interviewing and that really may not not
be what you want to do
you might want to be in a position where
you want a person to feel comfortable
with your company with your team so I'm
not necessarily a proponent of asking a
bunch of arbitrary code questions in
interviews but I figured it doesn't hurt
to know the answers so let's get started
we'll start with this one is kind of a
softball and I guess I'll preface this
by saying if your senior dev in here
you're probably this is old old turf for
you but hopefully maybe there's some new
things that you hadn't ever known
exactly how it works
I learned something this morning just
from researching this and if you are a
junior or beginner hopefully this will
sort of answer a couple questions for
you but this one is pretty basic but it
was one that I couldn't succinctly
answer explain event delegation event
delegation is JavaScript as it relates
to the Dom it basically means that if
you attach an event listener to Dom
element that listener is not only firing
on that Dom element it's actually firing
on every children in that so for
instance if you have a navigation and so
you've got an unordered list and you've
got list items and then you've got
anchor tags inside that navigation what
you have if you add an event listener to
the UL in essence you're actually adding
event listeners to all of the children
as well so it's something to and this
happens through a process called event
bubbling so sort of the inverse of the
idea of delegating down bubbling is when
it comes back up so events on an element
will bubble up to all of their parents
so when you click upon that a you're
actually clicking on the Li and you're
clicking on the UL and you're clicking
on the body ultimately so that that's
the concept of event bubbling so how it
actually works out in practice ways that
I found it useful are for instance if
you have live edits to a form that you
want to track
and you've got to form with a group of
inputs in here let me have to go them
over here to scroll yeah
but you've got all different types of
inputs and you want to maybe test when
they blew out of one of these inputs or
they key up or something like that well
you could go through and you could
target each one of these individually
you could grab all of them by a specific
tag and then you could do this the
special loop over them in order to add
an event listener to every single one so
that would totally work and then you'd
have one function that would you would
probably have to create a different case
for what type of thing it is in there
but you can bind to it but you can also
just simply bind to the parent so just
grab the form itself and everything
inside of it that can change that can
fire a change event is going to fire a
change event and so your form would run
and then in here you might have some
sort of switch based on the name of that
element or something like that and this
kind of demonstrates for us this wasn't
part of the the questions but it's sort
of a bonus tip bit you'll notice that
when I'm listening to kind of a more
Universal event on looking for child
elements that would trigger it I want to
use event target not event current
target and so that's a bonus little
tidbit that the difference between
target and and current target whenever
on an event listener is that target is
the actual thing that was clicked
whereas current target is what you
attach the event listener to so if
you've ever wondered what that is I had
to answer that question like just last
week so so that's that's a little bit
about the Dom moving on next question
explain why the following doesn't work
as an if B well in order to answer that
I actually didn't know what an if he was
so what is an iffy if he stands for
immediately and vote
function expression so if you actually
ran this code the way that it looks
right now you would get a syntax error
in your browser and what you would want
to do is basically it's the idea of an
immediately invoked function expression
is basically I write this function and I
run it I just want to write it and then
run it immediately but you can't do it
this way and the reason why is has to do
with kind of another related question is
the difference between writing a
function as a statement or as a
definition and writing it as an
expression so in JavaScript
anytime we they're sort of you have
statements and you have expressions
expressions result in a value and that's
the concept of an expression so if you
like assign a variable and try to attach
a value to it that will be read and
interpreted as an expression and it will
create a value this creates more of sort
of like a reference but it's not an
actual value so you can't just run it in
fact if you sort of try to run this code
immediately this is how javascript is
reading it and it's like this doesn't
make any sense to me
you wrote this thing and then later on
you're trying to call a function that
you doesn't have a name this this is
weird so instead you need to but there
are a lot of benefits and I'll call it
get into the benefits of the second of
writing it this way how can I write it
that way and get it to run immediately
well you can make that function at an
expression simply by putting parentheses
around it so now that this is in
parentheses JavaScript is going to
interpret whatever is inside that
parentheses to be an expression not to
be a statement and then it can run
immediately so this is called an
immediately invoked function expression
so I guess that begs the question like
why
why would I actually need to use this
well in a lot of situations and and this
is probably if you're working within a
framework or something like that you may
not need to like you may never end up in
this situation but the next time that
somebody asks you to build like them a
simple web page then this is going to be
relevant again you do it in order to
control variable scope so if you wrote
this function that function is not going
to be available the variables inside
that are not going to be available
outside of that function and actually
the guy who's josh mock is speaking
right after me he wrote sort of the best
blog post that I found on this concept
and of like why you might want to
control that scope and it used to be I
think for software developers it used to
be more of an issue because we were
writing a lot of things with jQuery and
there were a million jQuery plugins that
could be in our application and they all
had very dumb and plain naming
conventions and I was like I want to use
dumb and plain naming conventions in my
application so so this is how you do it
and it kind of relates to another
question on this list is that why in
general is it a good idea to leave the
global scope audible website and not
touch it and it's because you can't
predict the future
so 27 years ago Robert Zemeckis
predicted that the Cubs would win the
World Series in 2015 and boy was he
wrong he was a year off what an idiot
but seriously like you don't know
especially if you're building that that
web page for your friend like what
they're gonna want to put pull in what
kind of libraries and you want to
control your variable names so you never
have collision within your scope it also
allows you to maintain independence and
it makes it easier to write your own
code you call things whatever you want
because it's self-contained so that's a
little bit about scope kind of adding on
to that concept is this word
which is probably my favorite javascript
word which is hoisting explain hosting
and before I wrote this talk I actually
had no idea like what this was I had
observed it but I had never quite
understood it it means that all
variables that are declared using var so
this was kind of a specific problem well
I'll get into how it's been addressed a
little bit but all variables using four
are declared at the top of any given
function scope whether you really know
it or not whether you sort of like it
another or not and this actually
includes the functions that are written
as statements hold on where were they so
the top example this would include those
as well those are hoisted so this is
kind of an example of what you might see
but this is I used to try and do this
all the time I would say okay I've got a
variable and under this condition I want
that variable to be this and in this
other condition I want the variable to
be this and I would just just be like
well I haven't like create this variable
anymore I'll create it here and then and
here I'll create it and then maybe I
have another case where I don't need to
create the variable yeah I've saved
memory or something thought about myself
in my head but if you use a linter or
something like this you will probably
notice that this chokes this does not
like you to write it like this it would
say something like action is already
defined on line six because this is in
reality what is a happening behind the
scenes that you don't even know about
but javascript is taking that var and it
is creating var action up here at the
top and then what it's seeing here is
that you're trying to declare this
variable that's already been declared
not only are you assigning it a value
again but you're declaring it again and
it's like this is what are you doing
this is what job
scrip is actually doing to your code if
you write functions as statements like
this those functions are actually all
being hoisted to the top the entire
function this is sort of why and I had
never really understood this but
sometimes I would write a function and I
would try and call it and it would say
that it was undefined but then I would
move it in another place in the code and
it would work but then other functions
didn't seem to work that way well it all
boils down to whether you write them as
statements or assign them to variables
so so yeah Lehner's will kind of bark at
you about this because it's sort of not
clean code and it's but that actually
works in the browser browser hasn't had
no problem with it
but it means what hoisting means is that
technically this works you can have your
whole if statement you can assign value
to it assign a different value and then
declare it further on down in the code
and this is totally fine for JavaScript
and actually in the browser so this is
this is pretty absurd this is one of the
reasons why like people say that they
hate JavaScript and whatever and we have
a bad reputation whatever
so in walk this has kind of been
addressed with es6 and the idea of
constant and lead so constant and let
are ways of assigning variables that are
not wasted they are actually even more
than scoped within the function that
you're in they're scoped within the
block that you're in so if you're just
in this in this if statement you can
have variables that are scoped within
there that the outside part of the
function will have no knowledge of I
would say that that this makes more
sense like the more that I develop of
wanting to control this kind of
initially I was like everything can know
about everything I don't care but this
is really good for kind of performance
and things like that to scope things as
closely to where you want to use it as
possible and it sort of gives you more
control
and again like I mean your colleagues
might not like you but if you want to
use like VAR x equals this and VAR y
equals that you can and you can use it
all over there's a really good article
about it by the german doctor axel rauch
meyer about this variables in scoping in
es6 I would highly recommend checking it
out so I guess the question is sort of
after knowing these things what do we do
with the knowledge of hoisting like does
it actually change the way that we write
our code and I'm really I'm not gonna
touch this one this is like I think that
this has been pretty well argued ever
since constant and let came out of like
which ones you should use but I do see a
value in and declaring things as closely
to where you're going to use them and I
think part of my original intention here
this is what I learned about hoisting
was hosting constant and let give you
block scoped variables and hoisting was
basically trying to fake that the whole
time so constant and let are basically
solving the problem that's existed in
JavaScript of we want to do this and we
can't so we use hoisting to sort of fake
it so I'll probably be writing constant
and let mostly but so speaking of I've
used the word declare a lot there's
another question of like the what is the
difference between a variable that is no
undefined or undeclared so we'll start
with undeclared it is not simply a short
live show on Fox anybody ever see
undeclared yeah if you like freaks and
geeks you might check out undeclared
it's not as good but
you know so undeclared is basically when
you try and use a variable that that
you've never sort of used before you've
never written out far foo equals or
Const foo equals but you try and use it
in some kind of manner so that's a
pretty simple concept of what is
undeclared it's just you you forgot
something somewhere or you ripped out
some code in my case you ripped out some
of your co-workers code and now it's not
working
so that's undeclared undefined is it's a
little bit different undefined means
that you have declared it but it doesn't
have a value it has not been assigned of
value so these are all up here at the
top are all kind of examples of ways
that you might get undefined so if you
just declare a variable don't assign a
value if you have an empty object or you
try and grab something on an object and
it's not there you'll see undefined same
goes for like the index of an array if
nothing is there or if you run a
function and the function doesn't return
anything so that which is totally fine
to do undefined is not it's not always
undeclared is sort of something's gone
wrong but undefined you could get for
all kinds of reasons though it's not
necessarily an indicator that something
that's gone wrong the cool thing is with
constant is that you can only use
constant whoa look at that you can't you
are forced with constant to assign a
value to it whenever you declare so that
may change actually the way that you
want to use things because in a lot of
situations I don't want to do that I
want it to create a variable and then
have it changed depending on situations
so but that that is kind of nice because
you'll never sort of have the problem of
a constant being undefined and then you
have
oh yeah I've got this whole list of
important information
oh it's also false see which kind of
plays into that it's not necessarily an
indicator that something's wrong
you can definitely use it if in some
kind of logic condition if you're
looking for false ii know is a little
bit different and like it's kind of
nuanced but knoll is a value it's just
not a value you know no is actually the
interpreted as having a value that value
is not it's a nothing value it's a way
of sort of creating in a placeholder
assignment for something that would have
maybe other values you see this all the
time especially like if you're dealing
with an api you you might have something
on an object that's returned from your
api you might see the key there and the
keys value is null and that's that's
completely right and if you ever have a
situation where you need to sort of zero
out a value null is a great tool in
order to do that because because the
idea of zero as a number well that's
actually a value or zero as a string
well that's certainly a value so you can
use null instead yeah look through my
notes here so finally what the question
is if you how do you go about checking
for any of these states well the first
one is kind of easy undeclared will
usually find you I say usually but it
doesn't always find you because if
you're trying to assign a value to a
variable that hasn't been declared
javascript will totally let you do that
and it will go ahead and attach that
value to the global scope which is
really bad so essentially all that stuff
that I talked about about not touching
the global scope
javascript will let you just do that if
you leave off the the word bar so be
careful use a linter that's what I would
advise for there and this is another one
of the reasons why people hate
JavaScript about whatever haters now if
you want to check for undefined this
also kind of sucks because if you check
you can use type of it's really handy to
check for like if it's a number or if
it's a string or whatever if you try and
do use type of it will return undefined
as a string which is like frustrating
because all of a sudden we're dealing
with like this information that is in a
different type than what it actually is
so you can't use type of this inequality
checks because you've got this word
undefined as a string undeclared
variables will also return undefined if
you try and type of them now I'm
beginning to see why people hate
JavaScript and if you so the preferred
method would be to use a triple equals
to check if something is undefined and
not not not in this string by the way
even though that doesn't make any sense
because that yeah anyway so because if
you look for undefined as a string and
check it against undefined even though
this is what the console spits out it
will fail so yes check for undefined
with triple equals and the reserved word
undefined with null type of null
actually returns an object it will say
that you have an object this is a bug in
JavaScript this is a literal bug in
JavaScript that they are not fixing
because they have higher priorities and
by they I mean me because it's a
community like it's all falls on our
show all of our shoulders so but you can
also use the triple equal
with the reserved word null in order to
check for no and then finally like this
triple equals thing is just it's always
a great question
but what is the difference between
double equals and triple equals and so
here's an example foods undefined bar is
null and food double equals bar is true
yeah yeah that makes sense
essentially the what you have when you
use double equals is a check for
equality and JavaScript sees null and
undefined as both sort of having no
value and and says that those are equal
even though they are not the same type
of thing so triple equals is always
going to check for equality and type and
if anybody here is like done any sort of
like recent learning I'm gonna everybody
loves audience participation right how
many people have been told
always use triple equals no matter what
you've been lied to been lied to people
the reason people tell you that is
because they don't think you're smart
enough to understand it and use it
correctly but you can absolutely use
this correctly and if you know what
you're doing and you want to use the
double equals go ahead and use it and
put a little comma above it for the rest
of your developers to like not go in and
change your PR or be mad at you because
you know what you're doing so that's
pretty much it I'm gonna I'm gonna skip
the event loop because it really
deserves its own talk I just had it in
there because I thought that yeah
nevermind I knew I was not gonna have
time for that but just in case so anyway
you guys since you're at this talk you
were hired hopefully you get a boss just
as fun as Kimmy Schmidt boss wherever
you go to work and there are a ton more
of these up
html5 boilerplate I it was a fun
exercise for me to just go through these
and be like which of these can I not
answer quickly cannot answer well but I
just want to sort of say at the end of
this talk I I've been doing this for
about five years and I've am now sort of
like the senior guy on my team and
everything else but it doesn't really it
doesn't really account for a whole lot
necessarily that you can answer these
questions like super well my
encouragement to anybody at this
conference who's sort of like me feeling
really overwhelmed and really like I
just don't know how I'm gonna actually
apply this to my application coming the
next day I just really encourage you
just keep moving forward building
whatever it is that you're building just
build good software I think a lot of
times as developers we focus on the
tools that we're using the best way to
use those tools the most efficient way
which I totally get and it'll totally
love to do but we lose sort of focus on
like that we're here we're getting paid
to deliver badass software and if we
just focus on that then the tools we use
in the decisions and the learning it's
going to come alongside that and happen
as well we don't have to like learn all
this stuff first and have all these
perfect answers or even really know the
perfect terminology for what it is that
we're doing in order to make awesome
software and I am a pretty good example
of that because I won't say that I can
make software without knowing whatever
it is that I'm doing so
anyway that's that's the talk the slides
are up on my website if you want to have
them and then I've got two minutes so I
will take questions
am i what my brother-in-law is a pilot
and I thought that I mean that's
admittedly a very douchey picture so I
apologize but like the other one that I
had was was me inside the head of a
dinosaur that was my original picture
and yeah anyway I would love to be a
pilot because I thought it was I thought
it was awesome but other questions yeah
right right yeah I mean I think that
that is like that's a really key piece
is understanding that the question
themselves are sort of arbitrary
sometimes when you're trying to test and
I understand the the desire to use them
in order to kind of vet people and but I
think that maybe better questions to ask
would be like how do you handle a
situation where you've you've said that
you would meet a sprint deadline and you
realize that you're not gonna meet that
deadline what do you what do you do in
that situation or what do you do when
your designer comes to you and you've
already had something scoped out and you
are already two weeks into a sprint
developing something and your designer
wants more changes how do you handle
that situation like kind of more I think
what you can probably dig deep if you
come up with sort of clever questions
about how a person actually works is
hopefully they're gonna use the
technical stuff in their answer and
that's going to give you the vetting
that you need so that would be my hope I
think that the thing about the interview
questions like that is that yeah I mean
it's creating this adversarial situation
I just did one recently like a last
month and it was with my first initial
interview was with two people that were
on the dev team not with a hiring
manager so I kind of immediately knew of
they're weeding me out here and then
they had me do a code test and I was
like oh man I got this no problem like
if they put me up to a code test it'll
be no problem
and I was like panicky I was like I you
know and that's really just not how it
doesn't really mimic actual work
behavior you'd never be in a situation
that you would be under the gun like
that so it's not necessarily a good
indicator but yeah Ryan was mentioning
like a code a code challenge that a
prospective employer gave that was was a
homework assignment and it was basically
they gave you JSON and they gave you you
an API endpoint or a blob of JSON and
they were like just just make a UI out
of this like that could be something
really cool as long as it doesn't sort
of take so much of the person's time and
it wouldn't be worth it for them but
yeah yeah that's a great point right
right
Yeah right totally I think I'm
officially out of time but I'd love to
continue this conversation with anyone
after the session so thanks everybody
[Applause]